[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 16 janvier bienvenue dans
cette édition du 7 8 journal sur tv 60
18 26 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition
depuis deux ans elle sillonne les
yvelines et l'île de france une société
basée à trappes propose de livrer du
carburant à domicile l'approvisionnement
se fait au dépôt de coignières et le
service est réservée pour le moment aux
entreprises de la région
un livre choc sur la police nationale
alexandre langlois a publié l'ennemi de
l'intérieur dans lequel il critique les
dérivés dysfonctionnements de sa
profession et des positions qui ont valu
à cet agent du renseignement
territoriale des yvelines une suspension
l'été dernier enfin la partie dédiée aux
élections municipales à plaisir l'élu
est à la tête de la commune depuis 2012
joséphine coleman ce berger sera
candidate au scrutin
la maire sortante les républicains
seront en course pour un troisième
mandat pour débuter le 43e jour de grève
contre la réforme des retraites avec une
nouvelle mobilisation
interprofessionnelle aujourd'hui près de
deux cent cinquante mille personnes ont
défilé dans les rues de la capitale
selon la cgt un chiffre en recul puisque
le syndicat annoncé 120 mille
manifestants la semaine dernière un
mouvement avait également avec également
des actions locales celles de 200
professeurs réunis hier devant le
rectorat de l'académie à versailles pour
exprimer leur colère ils ont
symboliquement vide et leur cartable
contenant manuel caillet et fournitures
scolaires et des enseignants du lycée
base quant à rambouillet en te occuper
leur établissement la nuit dernière en
signe de protestation aussi à la réforme
du baccalauréat des actions se sont
déroulées aujourd'hui devant les mairies
de vélizy et de meulan et devant le
siège de cmr à elancourt et vous voyez
un cette assemblée générale des cg de la
cgt cheminots de versets qui étaient
réunis en assemblée générale je le
disais devant la gare des chantiers ce
matin et qui a voté une nouvelle
reconduction de la grève pour demain
demain vendredi justement le réseau des
transports sera encore perturbé vos
conditions de circulation à retrouver
sur les sites du transilien et de la
ratp
avoir une station service dans sa poche
grâce à son smartphone c'est l'idée
lancée il y a deux ans par la société
refoule installé attrape un service de
livraison de carburant à domicile
proposés essentiellement aux entreprises
pour l'instant le reportage de rayon
quelques clics suffisent sur cette
application dédiée pour commander son
carburant depuis deux ans la société
refoule basée à trappes propose une
station-service ambulante dans les
yvelines ainsi que paris et sa petite
couronne
l'idée est partie d'une expérience
personnelle mon frère et moi nous étions
sur paris et puis un soir nous sommes
tombés en panne d'essence
voilà donc on s'est dit c'est tellement
simple aujourd'hui de se faire livrer
des pizzas de se faire livrer tout un
tas de choses
de là est né un début de projet on a
commencé à chercher vis-à-vis de la
législation des lois et des
autorisations et ça nous a pris quatre
ans aujourd'hui l'entreprise d'une
vingtaine de salariés compte une
cinquantaine de clients essentiellement
des entreprises la société
s'approvisionnent au dépôt pétrolier de
coignières la flotte est pour l'instant
composé d'une vingtaine de véhicules
chaque camion un type de carburant
différents et peut transporter neuf cent
soixante litres comme aux adultes
organisé vous avez le même tarif qu'à la
station service la plus proche
ensuite après nous on met notre notre
prix aux services sis aux alentours d'un
café un peu plus d'un café on est aux
alentours de 2 euros 2 euros 50 refoule
propose également le gonflage des pneus
et le nettoyage des vitres objectifs
pour cette année 45 véhicules
supplémentaires
le recrutement d'une vingtaine de
salariés et l'élargissement de ce
service aux particuliers et grandes
agglomérations comme lure où bordeaux
mon premier invité dans ce journal
alexandre langlois bonsoir bonsoir êtes
le secrétaire général du syndicat de
police est vigie agent au service
départemental du renseignement
territoriale des yvelines et vous avez
publié récemment ce livre l'ennemi de
l'intérieur dérivés fonctionnement
dysfonctionnements dérivés
dysfonctionnements de la police
nationale c'est aux éditions talma
studio un livre choc et critique sur
votre profession et qui revient
notamment sur le contexte d'état
d'urgence la sphère benalla et aussi sur
la mobilisation des
j'ai déjeuné qui aborde aussi la
question de votre suspension
l'été dernier pour vos prises de
position vous avez été mis à pied pour
une durée d'un an avec six mois avec
sursis vous avez repris votre profession
il y à peu on en parlera tout à l'heure
ce livre pourquoi l'écrire est ce que
c'est une certaine forme de vengeance ou
au contraire c'est témoigner témoigner
des désillusions vous avez pu avoir au
sein de votre profession en l'écriture
du livret commencé avant que je souhaite
qu'une version donc il n'y a pas de
vengeance ça va laisser plus de temps
pour le terminer après c'est pas une
forme de désillusion c'est qu'en interne
on a essayé de se battre avec le
syndicat pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses avec des graves dérives et
dysfonctionnements en voyant que ça ne
fonctionnait pas ce que tout était
verrouillé
en interne on s'est dit il faut alerter
le public et donc je me suis mis à
écrire pour alerter la population
et dire qu'on a besoin d'être pourrait
former finalement la police est au
service de la population
d'où le de cet ouvrage et avant de
parler de ses dérivés dysfonctionnements
vous revenez aussi sur le pourquoi de
votre engagement au sein de la police
nationale en 2005 pourquoi avoir eu
envie en 2005 justement de vous engager
avec ce concours de police réussit et de
vous engager au au sein de la police
nationale
j'ai envie de m'engager au service de la
population y avait plusieurs professions
que j'aurais pu faire c'est lequel ma
préférence c'est la police nationale
j'ai eu plusieurs expériences la
première c'est que j'avais un ami mon
papy qui était commissaire au verger on
avait discuté puis après comme
l'expliquent dans le livre pendant mes
études je travaillais juste à côté
université de saint quentin en yvelines
juste travailler la nuit à côté
également et générer un autre collègue
de travail qui a passé le concours aussi
donc on discutait on s'est dit tiens
auto service des gens en tant que
policier
ce serait bien et aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez votre parcours est ce que vous
avez le sentiment que ces valeurs pour
lesquelles vous êtes engagés ont été ont
été bafoués mais c'est le sentiment que
j'ai donc c'est pour ça que en tant que
policier j'ai de quoi tuer mon
engagement au niveau syndical pour c'est
pour moi un prolongement de mon combat
de policiers pour défendre les valeurs
des policiers les valeurs républicaines
nous vous êtes engagés de manière
syndicale depuis 2010 c'était au sein de
la cgt qui est devenu ensuite cgt vigier
aujourd'hui une scission entre la cgt
vigie vous êtes aujourd'hui secrétaire
général de vie tout est fait
quand on voit votre parcours dans la
police il ya énormément de faits de
menaces d'intimidation de plantes aussi
il ya eu cette sanction
on y reviendra tout à l'heure qui est
intervenue l'été dernier on a
l'impression que c'est un parcours quand
même qui a été semé d'embûches votre
votre parcours c'était semé d'embûches
puisque dans là malheureusement dans la
police c'est le pas de vagues qui prime
c'est les bons petits soldats qui
exécute et même des fois une demande de
l'abattage statistiques mais pas de
protéger la population
et puis moi ça me révolte est donc je me
suis battu et on a essayé de me faire
taire de différentes manières j'ai plein
coeur disait pendant deux ans et le pire
dans l'histoire c'est que même qu'on
attaque en justice la justice nous donne
raison
le ministère refuse d'appliquer des
décisions de justice donc en fait c'est
kafkaïen et au bout d'un moment
l'écriture d'un livre permet d'expliquer
tous à ce que les gens ne peuvent pas se
rendre compte la folie interne
l'abattage statistiques cette guerre des
chiffres dont vous parlez dans votre
livre vous pensez qu'elle est à
l'origine justement de tous et toutes
ces dérives tous ces dysfonctionnements
que vous dénoncez les quins alésia bien
amplifier moi j'ai commencé la police à
cette époque là il y avait d'autres
problèmes et d'autres dysfonctionnements
précédemment sendin créer des nouveaux
et amplifier certains qui étaient avant
et finalement la quantité dans une
entreprise privée qui un but financier
on comprend comment ça peut se mesurer à
services publics venir à l'aide à la
personne ça ne peut pas se mesurer les
plus anciens nous disait qu'on rentre au
commissariat comme arte ras quartier
calme on les féliciter pour leur bon
travail
la politique du chiffre à fait vous êtes
des gros mauvais des gros nuls donc on
va chercher l'infraction
plutôt que de les prévenir et les
empêcher alors vous remettez en cause le
fonctionnement interne de la police le
manque d'indépendance de l'igpn la
police des polices les querelles entre
syndicats
la différence aussi de traitement selon
le grade vous parler notamment d'une
situation d'un haut gradé qui sera moins
inquiété pour un accident mortel qu'un
crs policiers accusés de vol de ce texte
et c'est pour ça que vous parlez de
l'ennemi de l'intérieur finalement c'est
à l'intérieur de cette police nationale
qui
que vous dénoncez ces dysfonctionnements
le titre est fait pour chacun mettre la
réponse qu'il veut sur l'ennemi
l'intérieur gina plusieurs tout au cours
du livre il ya les écologistes
l'intendant les la hiérarchie policière
sur ces messieurs castaner lille prend
sera plutôt à moi mais voilà c'est
chacun qui sera sa propre opinion et
l'exemple que vous donniez effectivement
il ya un commissaire qui tue une
personne en état d'ivresse il prend la
fuite et sa sanction être muté à ajaccio
rien du tout d'autres il finit sa
carrière à ajaccio toujours bourré et un
autre de nos collègues comme vous ai dit
ok on sait respect quatre textes signés
possession admistration a demandé trois
mois d'exclusion parce que c'était un
sale voleurs nous l'avons défendue il a
quand même eu 15 jours n'a pas pu
descendre en dessous et du coup qu'est
ce que vous demandez au travers de ce
livre est ce qu'il ya un but recherché
avec la publication de ce livre
le but recherché c'est que il ya un
débat public sur le sujet de la police
qui finalement au bout d'un an de
dérivés dysfonctionnements aggravé et de
qu'on ne peut plus cacher monsieur
macron enfin pris la mesure du problème
étant comment il va le réseau des ce qui
va poser la question à ceux qui ont
causé les problèmes ce qui est selon le
times pas la bonne solution
où est ce qu'on va aller relire le débat
comme il a pu le faire pour l'écologie
laisse moi c'est que la population
puisse avoir les clés pour donner les
réponses adéquates
est ce que vous avez reçu de nouvelles
menaces depuis la publication de ce
livre on rappelle vous avez repris le
travail il ya peu après une suspension
six mois ferme
il y avait six mois de suspension avec
sursis vous avez repris le travail il ya
peu donc j'appelle le travail les six
mois avec sursis ils ont cinq ans pour
faire sauter le sursis je rappelle que
j'ai été uniquement sanctionné pour mon
activité syndicale professionnellement
et aux notes et 6 sur 7 étant un bon
fonctionnaire donc dans mon service ils
étaient contents de me revoir
et après je n'ai pas eu de nouvelles
menaces après on attend la suite parce
que nous avons beaucoup d'affaires en ce
moment en cours et l'administration
ayant choisi aussi la technique de nous
sur chargé d' attaque en diffamation
en espérant que nous ne pouvons plus
payer nos frais d'avocat plutôt que de
se battre sur le terrain des arguments
merci alexandre l'emploi secrétaire
général du syndicat vigie agents du
renseignement territoriale des yvelines
et je rappelle que vous avez publié ce
livre l'ennemi de l'intérieur dérivés
dysfonctionnements de la police
nationale c'est aux éditions telma
studio les recettes alors est avec nous
l'entreprise blue ns blue line et à
propose des services de téléassistance
elle organisait des journées portes
ouvertes dans ses locaux de d'elancourt
lors de ce rendez-vous la société a
présenté sa nouvelle plateforme
connectée au domicile et aux
établissements de santé trente mille
français bénéficient d'une assistance
par téléphone mais la nouveauté c'est la
vidéo blu line et à vérifier en cas d'
alerte si l'usager a besoin d'être par
vidéo assistance les propos recueillis
par mathilde demi
on accompagne on prend soin de personnes
âgées dans le théâtre vos parents ou de
vos grands-parents h 24 7 jours sur 7 et
autour de personnes très âgées ou en
situation d'handicap
pourquoi cette plateforme unique va tout
simplement parce que nous avons lancé un
service de visio assistance et donc on
peut désormais aider les personnes à
distance en cas d' alerte on va pouvoir
les voir va pouvoir échanger avec elles
et dans certains cas comme elle n'arrive
pas à parler bas c'est plutôt pratique
dans l'actualité également après un jeu
dédié aux enfants l'association yvelines
environnement dédié un concours aux
entreprises elle est destinée à
l'ensemble des sociétés du département
l'initiative et en partenariat avec la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
yvelines et le conseil départemental le
but concilier efficacité énergétique et
performance économique dans une démarche
de croissance durable pour participer
les entreprises doivent répondre à l'un
des critères et des critères retenus par
le concours ils sont à consulter sur le
site internet divine environnement
tourisme yvelines yvelines environnement
pardon est les propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous avons pensé qu'il était très
important de valoriser le rôle des
entreprises en matière d'environnement
car beaucoup d'entre elles dépensent
certaines argent pour justement mettre
aux normes normalisé pour éviter un
certain nombre de problèmes concernant
l'environnement
le département des yvelines est un
département où l'environnement a toute
sa place
c'est un département rural
même si nous avons nous sommes en
proximité des grands centres économiques
et nous avons un centre économique dans
les yvelines la qualité de
l'environnement c'est un atout est
véritablement à une source
d'attractivité pour le département des
yvelines
un convoi je leur appel lancé par
l'association yvelines environnement
c'est bien ça le nom de l'association
les entreprises qui a souhaité
participer au concours ont jusqu'au 27
mai pour s'inscrire
un dossier technique et à envoyer à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran un mot de sport l'eco trail de
paris fête cette année sa 13e
dition l'épreuve qui sera organisée au
mois de mars relie à chaque année est
les yvelines au premier étage de la tour
eiffel au programme cinq distances dont
1 80 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines la conférence
de presse était organisée aujourd'hui et
jeudi nicolas landry est nickel et demi
d'euros étaient sur place
l'eco trail de paris l'une des courses
les plus importantes en ile de france
cette année quatorze mille personnes se
sont inscrites pour l'épreuve
la conférence de presse avait lieu au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
cette année les qautre elle proposera
cinq formats les distances 10 18 30 45 à
80 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et 80 km c'est
beaucoup
c'est un parcours qui est quand même
assez exigeant on parle de du domaine de
l'île loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines avec un territoire elle est
aidée des parcours qui passe par buqueux
versailles et et autres cette exigence
est démonté ces des descentes c'est des
changements de rythme et c'est de la
distance ont beaucoup ifo l'entraînement
il y aura une touche de glamour sur
cette eco trail quatre miss france vont
gravir les marches de la tour eiffel
pour l'association les bonnes fées
cette année nous avons veille malama
chavez maeva cook et marie l'orphelin et
une 4e encore qui est en train de se
motiver
franchement c'est bon enfant on le fait
vraiment pour notre association
grâce à l'argent qu'on va pouvoir
récolter cette année on va pouvoir
financer 150 et craint des faits sont
des sacs qu'on distribue dans des
maternités à des femmes dans le besoin
la course comprend également plusieurs
partenaires dont le département des
yvelines
les deux épreuves principales de celle
du 45 et du 80 km par taddei vinh
respectivement du château de versailles
et de la base de saint quentin
en usine et puis aussi parce qu'il ya
les valeurs partagées avec l'eco trail
concernant le domaine du développement
durable la 13ème édition de l'eco trail
ce sera donc le 14 mars prochain départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
on retrouve notre rubrique idée de
sortie avec mélanie potier qui nous a
rejoint bonsoir mon sein de la rédaction
tv 78 cette semaine les rendez-vous aux
loisirs sont très technologique et oui
la commanderie à elancourt a choisi de
mettre en avant les nouvelles
technologies c'est le premier temps fort
de ce premier trimestre 2020
l'atelier des sciences propose entrer
dans la matrice c'est le nom de
l'exposition une exposition penser en
trois temps la première partie c'est un
cabinet de curiosité pour découvrir
l'histoire des nouvelles technologies
mais aussi les entreprises du territoire
spécialisés des innovations aussi qu'ils
sont liés au numérique avec des projets
de fab lab des projets de startups du
territoire par exemple autour des objets
connectés à l'internet des objets de la
smart city mais aussi de la cyber
sécurité
et puis enfin un des grands défis
le 21e siècle les sujets de
l'informatique quantique en des notions
qui peuvent paraître compliqué on
rassure les téléspectateurs mélanie
l'exposition s'adresse à tous les
publics
comme toujours les missions de la
commanderie c'est surtout d'être ludique
alors d'ailleurs la deuxième partie de
l'exposition est faite de petits jeux
d'animations qui permettent
d'appréhender tout cela on apprend à
coder une caméra identifie ce qui est
mis devant elle et la ville peut aussi
se terminer par un jeu très en vogue un
escape game
voilà c'est plutôt une escape room alors
le public à 45 minutes pour identifier
et neutraliser une source de
dysfonctionnements et de piratage sur
internet c'est un jeu qui amène à une
réflexion sur de nombreux sujets et pour
les intéresser toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur les sites qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et que
maintenant vous connaissez bien la
commanderie points ce qui point fr et
kiosques points ce qui pourrait faire
merci mélanie d'autres idées de sorties
retrouver dans votre émission 7,8
loisirs après ce journal la page dédiée
aux élections municipales pour clore ce
journal premier tour au programme le 15
mars prochain à montigny le bretonneux
une deuxième liste officielle se lance
montigny solidarité 2020 avec à sa tête
pierre déjean candidatures de gauche qui
partira finalement seul après des
négociations qui ont échoué avec le
groupe alternative innovante n
écologique et solidaire
marylène iapichino pour le sujet élus
d'opposition de 2007 à 2014 derrière
sandrine grand gang est membre
associatif de la commune pierre déjean a
été désigné comme tête de liste pour
montigny solidarité 2020 avec une
campagne orienté sur trois axes
principaux le premier est alors j'ai dû
premier parce qu'il faut commencer par à
mais ils sont où ceux équivalent en
valeur c'est la démocratie locale
le second c'est l'écologie et le
troisième c'est la solidarité schéma
membres du parti de gauche pierre déjean
rassemble derrière lui des colistiers de
différents partis ou sans étiquette mais
avec cette forte volonté de se
revendiquer de gauche avec ses valeurs
aucune investiture deux parties demandé
mais les soutiens seront bien accueillis
on considère qu'aujourd'hui la gauche
elle a des vins
elle a des valeurs fondamentales des
valeurs de fraternité et valeurs
d'humanisme des valeurs de solidarité et
que ce sont ces valeurs-là que l'on veut
clairement exprimée par rapport à la
population qui n'y en eut aucune
ambiguïté par rapport à cela
je pense que je serais quand même pas
parti sur une liste flou donc j'utilise
le terme exprès moi je veux
effectivement que la politique qui sera
menée sur une politique de gauche pour
faire du social rénovation des maisons
de quartier gratuité des transports est
mise en place d'un guichet unique sont
des propositions de cette liste beaucoup
de citoyens un moment donné se trouve
confronté à un problème et ne savent pas
à qui s'adresser
donc ce que nous envisagions c'est de
mettre à la disposition bien ce qu'on
appelle le guichet unique et qui
permettra de venir
et là nous aurons des agents municipaux
qui vont orienter les 39 noms ne sont
pas encore réunies mais la tête de liste
se montre confiante
joséphine commons berger bonsoir ansa
vous êtes la maire sortante les
républicains de plaisir vous serez
candidate pour un troisième mandat dans
la ville où vous avez été élu pour la
première fois en 2012
il est resté à trancher le nom de votre
liste c'est chose faite mais en laisse
qui dit avant ce désir avance pour cette
liste alors votre candidature a reçu
l'investiture de la majorité de droite
départementale ensemble pour les
yvelines à laquelle vous appartenez on
précise que vous êtes également
conseillère départementale vice
présidente du conseil départemental et
aussi de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous êtes aussi adhérente au parti des
républicains est ce que cette liste
portera cette couleur où elle va réunir
diverses sensibilités dans cette liste
qui est renouvelée à un plus de 50% avec
énormément de jeunes qui ont voulu nous
rejoindre et bien il y aura la majorité
de non inscrits il y aura des personnes
de pas mal de bord y compris aux
démarcheurs puisque la liste est
complète
aujourd'hui la liste est complète bien
sûr elle est prête depuis un moment
puisque nous avons commencé au mois
d'avril
et aujourd'hui on a je dirais presque
trop de monde autour de nous mais en
tout cas ce sont des personnes qui même
s'ils ne seront pas dans les dix seront
à côté de nous ce sont des sympathisants
on est actuellement dans une permanence
dans laquelle il ya eu beaucoup
d'énergie et beaucoup de l'ambiance
positive et je le disais vous avez été
élu pour la première fois en 2012
prenant la suite de joël regnault qui
avait démissionné à l'époque vous avez
été élus en 2014 au premier tour
pourquoi être candidate pour un
troisième mandat sera le second sur
lequel vous briguez en tout cas un
second mandat complet je pense que quand
on
prend en main je dirais une ville qui a
eu une vraie continuité depuis 2001 et
qui a mis en place des projets vraiment
aux fondamentaux et des projets de
dynamisme au niveau de la ville et bien
les grands projets en tout cas ont
besoin au moins de deux mandats pour
arriver au bout on a des projets qui
sont des projets très structurant sur la
ville qui sont des projets surtout sur
la protection des espaces verts puisque
nous avons des déménagements qui vont
nous libérer 20 hectares en centre ville
donc c'est un vrai enjeu est en même
temps un atout et puis également on a
des projets vous savez comme la refonte
complète du quartier du vélib ou mais
également le centre bourg c'est quelque
chose qui nous semble fondamental
d'accompagner puisque nous avons
enclenché tout ça sur ce premier mandat
mais si vous regardez votre dernier
mandat le bilan que vous faites c'est un
bilan avec de nombreux projets des
projets encore à metz pour les écouter
on le bilan va bientôt sortir dans
quelques jours il va être entre les
mains des plaisirs hu à plus de 98% des
choses auraient été faites y en a fait
même des choses supplémentaires que nous
n'avions pas prévu puisque nous avons
été pendant toute cette mandature l
écoute des plaisirs war avec bien sûr
des réunions comme on a toujours fait
mais aussi parce que la société a changé
pendant cette période et on s'est rendu
compte que les priorités qui était bien
présente en 2014 ne sont plus les mêmes
et donc on s'est adapté pendant cette
mandature avec quelques tensions entre
eux mêmes dans votre majorité les
dernières en date on rappelle en
septembre dernier trois de vos anciens
adjoints ont rejoint l'opposition
patrick jouin terre notamment qui sera
candidat face à vous ils ont dénoncé à
l'époque des divergences de points de
vues sur la gestion et l'orientation de
la ville est ce que c'est un regret
quand vous regardez votre mandat qui eut
ces tensions au sein de votre nom je
m'interroge surtout sur la période de
démission qui est une période 1 5 mois
des élections je pense que quand on a
des divergences dans une équipe on
parvient plutôt un an deux ans trois ans
avant on se rend compte assez vite que
les choses ne vont pas mais quand on a
tout voté ensemble à l'unanimité ça peut
paraître étonnant que tout à coup à cinq
mois des élections et bien il ait des
divergences et des départs en même temps
je dirais le départ de monsieur jean
terre si je peux le citer
eh bien il est d'autant plus étonnant
que c'est un départ qui n'est pas
vraiment de sa volonté puisque cet été
j'ai appris qu'il montait une liste
contre moi je lui ai demandé de
démissionner donc il a anticipé les
parties donc je pense qu'effectivement
nous n'avions rien plus rien à faire
ensemble
votre programme pour plaisir qui sera
articulée autour de quatre axes majeurs
un point notamment sur l'écologie c'est
un simple en convoi notamment émerger de
nombreuses communes c'est on peut pas
faire sans aujourd'hui non on peut pas
faire ça on s'en rend compte c'est pas
simplement une priorité collective je
dirais sur une sur une ville c'est
collectif au niveau national voire
international
on doit absolument accompagner cette
démarche là c'est une vraie volonté on
le sent et puis je pense que on a la
chance d'avoir une ville comme plaisir
qui est une ville à plus de 50% de
ruralité il faut la maintenir et la
développer donc c'était déjà un argument
que nous avions pris en 2014
et aujourd'hui non seulement des quelque
chose qu'on veut continuer mais qui est
vraiment attendu par la population et
donc on sera là pour continuer toutes
les démarches qu'on a mis en place et
l'écologie en tout cas c'est l'ambition
affichée pour le renouvellement du
quartier du val hibou qui a vocation à
devenir un éco quartier exactement dont
seulement les 65 millions d'euros que
nous avons réussi à avoir pour ce
quartier pour cette modification en
profondeur de ce quartier qui va non
seulement transformé le quartier du val
hibou mais l'ensemble de la collectivité
parce que ça va avoir un impact bien sûr
écoquartier ça nous semblait
indispensable il s'était aussi attendu
par les habitants puisque aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être un peu minérale il est
important pour voir les choses
différemment
et puisqu'on parle de ce quartier du val
et booth et il a été touchée récemment
par quelques soirées de violence urbaine
qu'est le travail est fait justement par
la commune quel travail est amené encore
pour faciliter cette tranquillité
publique en tout cas la favoriser
justement le fait je dirais d'avoir six
accompagnement financier pour changer le
quartier c'est une chose mais est
important aussi d'avoir une série
d'actions comme par exemple nos
médiateurs nous avons des médiateurs qui
sont des agents de la ville qui
travaille sur les quartiers des
relations et des collaborations étroites
avec bien sûr les associations qui sont
du quartier mais également avec la
mosquée puisque c'est quand même un
élément important il faut savoir que
tous les partenaires qui sont sur ce
quartier sont des personnes
qui ont une véritable un véritable
engagement sur les quartiers et
aujourd'hui avec les médiateurs la
police municipale la police nationale
également qui n'est pas kelly block
jeudi rnic est pas un corps qui vient
uniquement là je dirais pour pour m une
attitude bien au contraire
et puis aussi parce que les
transformations profondes que nous
allons faire dans ce quartier ont
véritablement changé la configuration du
quartier cette ouverture
j'avais pu constater que le silo est
tombé et donc ceux ci l'on ouvre déjà le
quartier à l'ensemble de la ville
puisque comme je les ai toujours dit
loew alibo est un quartier au coeur de
la ville et c'est un atout fondamental
alors plaisir qui a connu au cours de ce
dernier mandat l'intégration dans saint
quentin en yvelines depuis le 1er
janvier 2016 la commune fait partie de
cette agglomération vous en êtes la
première vice présidente est ce qu'on
peut parler d'intégration réussie ou ce
qu'il faut renforcer encore davantage ce
travail mené avec l'agglomération
je parle de d'intégration et également
de décentralisation c'est quelque chose
aujourd'hui qui est entre les mains même
du président de la république et du
sénat avec gérard larcher nous
travaillons là dessus
il est évident que nous sommes
actuellement bien intégré au niveau de
50 ans on arrive à trouver je dirais des
énergies communes
il faut qu'on trouve un projet commun
qui est un projet qui réunisse des douze
communes on en a véritablement le
potentiel moi je sais que depuis
longtemps je défends un projet de
territoire
aujourd'hui bien sûr c'est attendu par
tout le monde par tous les maires
j'imagine que nous serons à même de le
faire ensemble après les élections pour
encore une fois est bien mutualiser
davantage
et puis trouver des éléments encore plus
important pour pouvoir avoir des moyens
financiers parce que comme vous le savez
les collectivités seules aujourd'hui
avec les baisses de dotations et bien on
a beaucoup de mal à s'en sortir
je pense que ça peut être une
possibilité d'aller de l'avant
un dernier mot sur vos prochains rendez
vous de campagne joséphine coleman
verger quels sont-ils quand allez-vous
rencontrer la population plaisir aux
mais je suis déjà en lien avec
sur nous avons deux rendez vous mais je
fais des rencontres tous les jours avec
déplaisir hoa dans des familles dans des
groupes de personnes qui m'accueille
mais en même temps si vous le permettez
j'aurais tendance à dire que depuis 2012
c'est ma façon de fonctionner je suis
sur le terrain en permanence et donc
c'est pas parce qu'il ya la campagne
municipale que tout à coup je me mets à
rencontrer les plaisirs donc c'est une
continuité avec peut-être des précisions
un peu plus grands de notre bilan parce
que tout n'est peut-être pas visibles et
compréhensibles et puis nos prochaines
rencontres donc c'est au cosy et on a on
a un restaurant qui nous accueille et
puis également à la trappe orjiako
gastines ce sont deux rendez vous qui
sont sur notre site puisque nous avons
un site qui est important d'aller
visiter parce qu'il ya pas mal
d'informations dessus et puis je peux
vous dire que notre campagne sera
respectueuse elle sera souriante
dynamique et puis l écoute des plaisirs
roi comme nous l'avons toujours été avec
je dirais aucune agressivité
merci josefina coleman berger maire
sortante de plaisir vous serez candidate
pour un troisième mandat face à vous
pour le moment une autre candidature
officielle celle de patrick jean terre
remettons plaisir en marche c'est le nom
de sa liste et je précise également
qu'un appel a été lancé par le groupe
nous plaisir rendre la ville à ses
habitants pour constituer une liste
citoyenne pas d'officialisation encore
sur cette candidature voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci d'avoir suivi très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]